Getting anything better down there,
Johnny?
A lot of bent rods.
So we're just getting set up right now
on the regal sword.
We made the move down from crab ledge
last night.
Might just set up right in here.
Yeah.
You know, you just get panic
in panic mode about not getting
the paycheck and going home, we’re
90 miles away, a lot of fuel, you know,
probably 4 to $600 worth of fuel.
You just want to make a paycheck.
You want to be in the black
by the time the trip's over.
We came down here to pick up right
where we left off last season,
but so far, that hasn't been the case.
I'm really feeling the pressure to get
some meat on deck and defend our title
lock in,
we’re marking.
Yeah buddy!
be the right one.
Go, go.
There you go.
We need this fish bad.
We've got to get one today.
We already got guys ahead of us
on the leaderboard.
A nice big fish here.
We'll certainly make up some ground.
We've got a lot of work
to do to land this one, though.
Want me to take over for a bit Johnny?
You got.
Yeah.
Go nuts.
Yeah, baby.
Whoo!
Yeah we've been doing a lot of reverse
right now.
Just trying to keep up with this fish.
He's just plugging away.
So hopefully we can eventually
get this fish straight up and down
and fight him how we want.
Forward.
Oh, **** you ******* kidding me?
What the ****
that's around his tail.
Oh, I'll jump in for a while, Jonny.
Yeah, he's kind of all over the place.
He just kind of keeps wanting
to go to one direction, sweep the board
in reverse the whole time on them.
He won't settle into anything here,
so we want to get him up and down,
but we can't.
We're on a real one this time, you know,
no small fish today.
We need to get this one.
There's a few people already
on the leaderboard ahead of us.
You know, there's only a limited days
we can fish this year.
We've got to make sure every fish counts.
And we need to get this fish badly.
This fish is acting like a jerk.
If I'm being honest.
They kept swimming away and away and away.
We finally got him up and down here.
He's gotta be wrapped, so be ready.
Oh, yeah.
Here you go manny.
He was hooked in the tail.
Holy **** he was hooked in the tail!
Oh my God.
Holy crap are you kidding me?
Oh, my God.
He's a monster.
Here we go baby!
Yeah!
Needed that one boys.
Needed that one.
We knew it was a heavy fish.
Just because you can feel
the weight on the line,
but you could feel the paddle,
the tail the whole time.
But he wasn't tail wrapped.
We figured it was fowl hook somewhere,
but the hook is in the tail.
Look at that.
Well, that right
there is some damn good luck.
Oh, we needed that.
Must be nice.
Fat Tuna just got one.
Uh jealous!
So jealous.
Whenever you're ready.
Oh, yeah. Here we go boys.
Whoa he is round.
Let's put a tape on it.
95. Heck yeah, boys.
Nice.
Heck yeah!
All day long.
Let's get this guy cleaned out.
Ice up. Let's head home, baby.
That's incredible.